foreign
if they're the best team in Europe can
finally be decided in Istanbul the
domination of England is well
established the desperation is to win
the Champions League
one final has already been lost two
years on intimate land stand in their
way we do what we want we do it our way
we do it the hard way we've had the
tough times this is our time now I'm
telling you now this is our time Allen's
on a different level
any other player it's like a beast it is
to shut United up
the fans you go into work and they're
like oh yeah United you'll never do what
we've done but we're getting there like
it's a new world
Manchester United set the Benchmark with
their treble in 1999. the noisy
neighbors can match that on Saturday
night at The atter Turk Stadium
you know the correct portion of
obsession you know to desire to want it
when the obsession is a is a positive
word for the fact that we desire and
willing you know to try to do it but of
course the dream for all of us
already they've won the FA Cup by
beating United last weekend this is
about how a state and its Sovereign
wealth can be used to transform a club
and gain a soft power tool there's a
trophy and some geopolitical influence
to be won here
with owner shapeman saw the vice
president of the UAE and their
representative at the king's coronation
Abu Dhabi has provided the Financial
Muscle that's led to investigations into
how legitimately the squad has been
financed but critics are just seen as
envious of all the success success
that's just missing the Champions League
Rob Harris Sky News Istanbul